[Music]
hey Bill I'm Aaron and I'm from Scotland
and I went vegan after I watched
documentaries like before the flood and
conspiracy it presented me with lots of
terrifying information such as that from
EF al which suggests that 14.5 to 18% of
the world's global emissions are due to
animal agriculture and however world
watch suggests closer to 51% I was
wondering if you knew why there was such
a difference between these two figures
and whether you think adopting a vegan
diet is the best thing that you do as
individuals for the planet Aaron you
raised a very good point I don't know
why the two figures in those two studies
the documentary and the it was a
scientific paper or discrepant but it's
probably has to do with trying to essay
or figure out how much greenhouse gas is
created by cattle or other livestock and
the problem everybody is that livestock
eat plants then bacteria in their
livestock stomachs metabolize the plant
material into methane natural gas and
you can make all the jokes you want but
nothing is a very strong greenhouse gas
the first place I'd look to find the
reasons for the discrepancy between the
two figures is in the amount of
greenhouse gas supposed to come from a
cow or a sheep or goat so with humans
the human population getting so big that
it's we are raising so many farm animals
it's very reasonable that we're creating
a tremendous amount of extra methane
that wouldn't normally be it wouldn't
otherwise be there in the atmosphere and
that is causing global warming and
climate change happen more rapidly than
it would otherwise
however if humans weren't there animals
would be all over the place anyway it's
not clear that they'd be in these
concentrations though it could be a
difficult thing to measure but it's also
reasonable that agriculture researchers
are going to produce or breed farm
animals that produce less methane by
changing the bacteria that are in their
stomachs
that metabolized plant matter to get all
the way down to a plant-based diet might
be tricky for a lot of people however it
seems like a good idea
check in with me in a few months because
I noticed that my diet is becoming
increasingly vegetarian and so the next
little while I may be all the way over
why are you now Bill it's a great
question
I'm working it I'm working on it it's a
very interesting question and important
one and literally a huge one because
Dharma the Earth's atmosphere Thank You
Erin
[Music]